pas tout à fait plein de choses tournent
sans régler il paraît qu alors il ya un
truc qui tu arrives il te ramène
histoire de ouf pas de ce que pendant
une séance de plongée
tu as été attaqué par cette route un oui
c'est vrai c'est pareil dans une ferme
en wolof
il paraît que tu t'es battu avec les
requins à coups de bâton tient son lacet
soir raconte cette histoire parce
qu'elle est folle il s'est fait attaquer
par cette route 1 en fait c'était du
lourd dans l'eau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors
les gars sont pas tous bien sa classe
éco la dissymétrie ya beaucoup de
requins si tu dis ça pour benjamin
castaldi
elle a beau changer avant tout changer
alors c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
je suis parti en fait dans une odyssée
s'appelle l'odyssée bleus et je voulais
rencontrer les les dauphins sauvages et
donc il fallait traverser toute une mer
c'est la mer des caraïbes et tout ça et
c'est une immense piscine et à un moment
j'ai fait de la plongée bouteille et
[Rires]
profondeur non mais sérieux j'ai plongé
avec mon binôme
il y avait deux ce qu on appelle ça les
monitrices qui nous qui nous encadraient
et puis tout d'un coup il ya un requin
qui arrivait de requins c'était pas
prévu je n'étais pas une foire et de
requins et les sept se sont mis à
tourner autour de nous comme ça enfin
efficaces qu'elles ont fait elles nous
ont lâchés
c'est donc moi j'étais à 40 mètres de
profondeur et c'est de ne pas faire à
celle ci a celsius un celtic
[Applaudissements]
il est vraiment
mais là
on retourne très bien
ah non j'étais très inspirée dé la
beauté là j'aime parce que mon regard se
dirigea et je vois comme un monument
c'est vrai un homme un chroniqueur en
voie de disparition
oui mais voilà donc on s'est retrouvé
avec mon binôme on était dos à dos et on
s'est mis un peu comme en mode
enfin catherine fait rien on n'avait
rien fait et donc voilà et tout d'un
coup ils nous on attend ils n'ont pas
bougé les monitrices son parti dont
juste donné de deux manches à balai on
s'est retrouvés je dois m'assurer aux
manches à balai non mais tu alors qu'est
ce qu'a fait et ba en fait je savais pas
ce que moi je m'étonne quand sa taxe a
dit quoi juste [ __ ] ta mère je veux
dire que quand il est attaqué tu sais
qui va t'attaquer il tournait autour
d'eux le détroit comme ça sinon plus
d'un coup il y en a qui s'est détaché du
cercle il est parti il est revenu en
mode torpille s'est peut-être que je les
ai vus arriver tout droit il faisait
jusqu'à jeudi suis né il va attaquer
donc j'ai pris le culte
[Applaudissements]
savoir où le dauphin
il faut que ça arrive à des gens mais ce
qu'il faut faire c'est que si vous voyez
un requin et que vous êtes au fond de
l'eau il faut s'allonger parce que le
requin en fait sa mâchoire inférieure
elle émue qui s'est pas attraper comme
ça il peut attraper que par en dessous
la chose n'est qu'en deuxième chose si
vous voyez un aileron arriver faut avoir
une super maîtrise de soi mais faut
surtout pas bouger se mettre en boule
chaque robot se mettre en boule parce
qu'ils y voient une boule ça n'intéresse
pas lui avoir le coeur net
oui bon on va pas faire deux ans le
temps donc tu t'es fait honnêtement j'ai
eu la peur de ma vie je croyais que
j'allais jamais revenir
et en fait à un moment il y en a un qui
s'est déclarée un peu le chef c'est lui
qui est parti qui est revenu à fond et
vous savez que quand un dauphin un
requin celui qui gagne c'est le dock se
tapent dans la tempe
oui moi j'avais appris ça en plongée
j'ai dit bon je vais essayer quoi et
j'ai pris le manche à balai jeu l'étape
et ça lui a rien fait il est revenue
deux trois fois et la troisième fois il
est parti une fois que le chef fait
partie le troisième et le deuxième est
parti pris et après pour un dauphin en
fait même si je suis dit [ __ ] je me
suis embrouillé par des rouges sur cette
émission pour jouer les vraiment l'ailé
pas dépouiller ton maillot non non c'est
que en fait quand tu te retrouves dans
une situation que ça c'est ta vie tu
trouves une énergie incroyable
révélation qui sortait des ordis gtg
j'avais peur évidemment mais à un moment
tu es obligé de te battre sinon tu
étudies à croquer quoi